The Joe Rogan Experience the leaked
document like what was your thoughts on
that because the whole thing was crazy
that this guy had access to it that and
I guess he was showing it to his friends
or something is that yeah well it seems
that way you know a lot of people kind
of were uh were criticizing the guy and
they they were kind of saying like well
look this guy's no Ed Snowden I mean he
didn't like take this to Glenn Greenwald
at the guardian right to have him vet
through it and properly disclose it he's
like bragging to friends on a Discord
server or whatever and essentially that
seems right to me like that does kind of
seem like what happened but again like
that's not the interesting story here
the interesting story isn't like what
this guy's deal was or what his motives
were the story is like oh the
government's lying to you again and also
that it's they have this uh information
that they claim is so vital that it's so
horrible he leaked it and yet you're so
reckless with it that you know it's like
it's funny I remember Glenn Greenwell
making this point when people would talk
about uh like people were at the
National Security apparatus or whatever
would be talking about how how Reckless
it is that Snowden just like gave all of
this information out and you're like
well then weren't you pretty reckless
too because like if this information's
so vital you didn't even know it was
gone right they didn't even know it was
gone until uh the guardian published it
and then they were like oh
I guess this guy took all of our
documents
um but another what did the documents
say well it was just right before that
one of the the other real interesting
thing
is that they came out so a a couple days
after uh the leak first like was getting
reported the
um Reuters had a piece an article uh
where they had three high-level U.S
officials under anonymity
said that you'll never believe this Joe
it had all the Hallmarks of Russian
disinformation and so isn't it just
amazing that they'll go and then like
two days later they completely gave up
on that and went let's just smear the
kid who did it you know like uh forget
all that stuff
um there were some some interesting uh
Revelations from from the documents
things like uh they um they're evidently
there are NATO and US military embedded
in Ukraine
um like help assisting them basically uh
which is which is pretty dangerous
um Western Special Forces operating
inside Ukraine the one document dated 23
March refers to the presence of a small
number of Western Special Forces
operating inside Ukraine without
specifying their activities or location
the UK has the largest contingent 50
followed by Latvia 17 France 15 in the
U.S 14 the Netherlands won Western
governments typically refrain from
commenting on such sensitive matters but
this detail is likely to be seized upon
by Moscow which has in recent months
argued that it is not just confronting
Ukraine but NATO as well
oh and essentially look this was the um
I think what when Putin ultimately
decided to invade Ukraine last year I
think basically what he concluded
was that they did it they brought
Ukraine into NATO even though Ukraine is
not an official NATO country at this
point they backed the coup that
overthrew the Democratic uh the
democratically elected government under
Yanukovych they poured weapons into the
country and they were doing
um joint training exercises with NATO
and the Ukrainian military and I think
Vladimir Putin was basically like we
told them this was our brightest of red
lines and they crossed it and I got to
do something now I'm not saying he
should have done this there's other
things he could have done
um there's lots of things I mean I don't
know exactly you get creative but he
could have cut off all natural gas to
Europe he could have dropped a nuke in
the ocean I mean he could have done
something before he did this you know
but he basically concluded that Ukraine
is de facto a member of NATO and if you
look at the way we're responding to this
whole thing he's he's kind of right
I mean like we're backing them all the
way because they were invaded that's
what we're supposed to do to a NATO
country you know
um and so this is bad that this comes
out although I gotta say I'm surprised
to some degree how much uh
you know they've I mean nor if the
Nordstrom bombing didn't you know like
do it I don't know if just like some
special forces being embedded there is
gonna like you know create some big
escalation